ce que hier merci de nous accorder cette
entrevue pour ma may myo lipow je vous
ai pas entendu parler d'austérité
aujourd'hui monsieur kouyaté vite que
vous le savez tous ce qui vous fait par
la non sans rien qui me fait peur je
laisse les gens choisir les mots qu'ils
choisissent d'utiliser mais l'austérité
ça sera autre chose on en voit non pas
une rigueur de gestion des finances
publiques où ils habitent et une
réduction de la vitesse de croissance de
dépenses mais une réduction des
enveloppes budgétaires ce qui est
absolument pas le cas actuellement mais
dans certains ministères c'est canon et
aucun ministère dont enveloppe diminue
tout le monde grandit notamment santé
éducation mais à des taux beaucoup
moindre l'admets mais en 97 98 lors
d'une importante réduction des
enveloppes de santé et d'éducation
c'est pas le cas je mens je préfère
parler de rigueur budgétaire parce que
sinon ça donne l'impression d'un
phénomène temporaire alors que la
rigueur doit être là pour rester il faut
continuer à dépenser moins congrès les
gens qui vivent c'est une compression
qu'ils y subissent 10 on parle
d'austérité alors qu'est ce que vous
leur dites aujourd'hui c'est nécessaire
parce que l'alternative c'est quoi
l'alternative c'est banaliser les
déficits en faire un autre un autre
savait que des sur les 30 derniers
budgets seulement qu'ils étaient
équilibrés au québec chaque fois que
c'est pas équilibré ça ça va sur la
dette
c'est la prochaine génération c'est cote
de crédit un ensemble de phénomènes qui
font qu'on doit absolument gérer ça de
façon sérieuse et prioritaire de faire
correctement puis en profiter pour faire
mieux les choses que ce soit pas
uniquement l exercice de rétrécissement
ou de compression mais surtout un
exercice d'imagination également qui
nous amène vers un horizon plus
favorable on a eu une année exigeante
devant nous je les dis aujourd'hui la
presse en gameiro qui s'en vient parce
que les effets de ces compressions là on
va aller s'en tire beaucoup dans les
prochains mois beaucoup t il y aura
certainement cette année encore une fois
une gestion exigeante à faire mais c'est
un an sur 2 400 ans d'histoire alors je
pense qu'on est capable de faire un an
de discipline peut par la suite avoir
des taux de croissance notamment
d'éducation santé qui sont plus proches
de ce qu'on avait anticipé
lorsqu on connaissait pas la réalité des
finances publiques mais jacques parizeau
disait hier qu'il y avait comme une
fixation presque religieuse danse dans
cet objectif du déficit zéro qu'est-ce
que vous
monsieur parizeau mais quand konami
absolument mais ça conduit parfois à
banaliser les déficits et c'est ce qu'il
faut arrêter de faire que max ait pas
banal un déficit parce que chaque
déficit va sur le net ça nous coûte 30
millions par jour de paiements d'intérêt
sur la dette ça c'est l'argent qui va
pas dans l'aude universités dans nos
écoles nos hôpitaux
il faut qu'on prenne soin quand même
vous qu'on prenne le contrôle de sa et
surtout qu'on est des budgets équilibrés
surtout lorsqu'il ya pas de grande
récession parce que le prochain choc
parce qu'ils y avoir un prochain choc de
l'économie mondiale
en quelques années il faut qu'on ait la
marge de manoeuvre à ce moment là pour y
répondre actuellement on est presque
menotté par notre situation financière
mais là on doit également posé des
gestes continuer de poser des gestes
pour le développement et la prospérité
il ya aussi la façon de faire parce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est pas la
première fois que ça se fait ça s'est
fait de façon plus importante c'est vrai
que sous lucien bouchard et les
compressions très importante mais il
tenait quand même à une certaine
consultation il essayait de deux
d'amener les syndicats les gens
d'affaires ensemble pour trouver un
consensus là dessus est ce que c'est
important à consultation oui oui il faut
que les décisions se prennent également
puisse en venir à cette époque qui en
reste pas moins que tout était largement
script et d'avancer au pas se faire
d'illusions le choix qui a été donné aux
gens c'est 6 % de réduction des salaires
de tout le monde où on fait autre chose
et autre chose malheureusement ça a
entraîné le départ de nombreuses
infirmières médecins ses obligations il
a regretté la casse et témoin de la
consultation alors on n'avait pas
entrevu ses conséquences la journée pour
vous est ce que c'est important oui
j'écoute mais je prends des décisions du
gouvernement sont élus pour décider on
sera jugé
moi je me soumets déjà désormais au
jugement des populations au terme du
mandat mais il faut qu'on avance on peut
pas continuellement tourner en rond et
ne pas avancer il faut qu'on mettre
derrière nous est nécessaire
ce nécessaire redressement des finances
publiques la santé par exemple les
omnipraticiens vous met en garde contre
des conséquences très dangereuse pour le
système de santé soit qualité des soins
les infirmières aussi vous entendez bien
sûr et puis justement si on réussit à
passer de l'année et maintenir
l'équilibré par la suite on peut
reprendre un rythme de croissance en
santé beaucoup plus compatibles avec ce
qui est nécessaire de faire maintenant
aux médecins jeudi à chaud suivante
ça fait des années qu'on voit le nombre
de médecins augmenter le revenu des
médecins a augmenté on envoie des
milliards et centaines de millions
d'âmes
les enveloppes des fédérations médicales
et malheureusement l'amélioration de
l'accès sur tout ces négociations ne pas
se faisait c'était comme ça que ça se
faisait les médecins disaient
donnez-nous ceci cela supprime ses
avantages et vous allez voir
l'accès va s'améliorer force est de
constater que ça ne s'est pas fait des
clauses la synthèse quiz en avait trop
de nous donner ce qu'ils pensaient
nécessaire de faire d'autant plus qu'on
avait de l'enjeu de la différence de
revenus entre médecins québécois et
soudure et du canada souvenez vous on
n'a plus vraiment cet enjeu là
aujourd'hui
alors moi j'espère que les médecins
d'ailleurs je crois que des
conversations en trouver docteur
barrette actuellement vont dire oui on
doit nous même posé un geste pour
améliorer l'accès c'est pas normal avec
le nombre de médecins qu'on a maintenant
on n'est pas un accès plus facile mais
est-ce qu'il ya eu une erreur au niveau
de la pédagogie parce que on dit que
votre gouvernement manque de compassion
de est assez froid dans ses coutures là
je pense par exemple aux femmes les
femmes qui vont être les plus touchés
par cette rigueur budgétaire qu'est ce
que vous leur dites c'est que justement
on a rétabli les choses qui étaient
négatifs pour les femmes premier les
services de garde la proposition du
gouvernement précédent d'augmenter tout
le monde de 7 à 9
c'était directement négatif pour les
familles à faibles revenus notamment
pour les femmes monoparentales à faible
revenu on a choisi de diminuer le coût
des services de garde pour ces personnes
à faible revenu alors il ya là un enjeu
excessivement important que j'ai pour
vous rappeler non plus toute la
controverse autour nashat qui frappait
directement les femmes devraient
représenter 75 % de la fonction publique
ce sont elles qui vont être les
premières jeu c'est elle qui utilisent
e-services en prime et leurs revenus les
ans que vous avez mesuré l'impact que ça
avait ça pourrait avoir sur les phares
avant aux halles est conscient malgré le
coût des plaques ont des comptes à
nouveau conscient également les impacts
différenciés comme pour les visites on
est conscient que tout le monde va
souffrir notamment les femmes du
déséquilibre chronique des finances
publiques et de l'endettement
parce qu'au bout de la rue au bout de
l'équation ce sont elles qui vont payer
la note
celle de la prochaine génération
notamment les jeunes parce que chaque
fois qu'on banalise un déficit qu'on dit
c'est pas grave on me laisser aller les
choses ne vous en faites pas tout va
très bien on envoie la facture aux
prochaines générations qui souvent ce
sont les fans qui vont les ramasser
cette facture mais je reviens à quelques
exemples ça c'est dans quelques années
entre souffre mais notre rôle c'est de
préparer
actuellement les personnes qui
travaillent dans le secteur public leurs
revenus vont continuer d'augmenter la
rappelons le il faut quand même établir
des choses comme elles sont à faire des
comparaisons qui doivent être faits et
encore une fois venir à l'alternative la
tentative c'est quoi abandonnée laissée
allée des déficits rester les bras
croisés dire que ce programme non on
n'est pas comme ça je ne ferai pas ça
parce que ce serait manquer mes
responsabilités mais quand vous regardez
le budget de michelle courchesne disait
ce qui fait ce que si l'ampleur de tout
ce qui est en train de se faire le
chambardement qui est en train de se
vivre au québec qui peut-être qu'ils
causent peut-être problème me disais est
ce qu'il fallait faire tout en même
temps si dit que je suis de ceux qui
croient que si on fait pas une chose
assez rapidement on fait rien parce que
justement la réaction normale d'une
société avec le changement et c'est
naturel toutes les sociétés sont mêmes
sidi ben non on est bien comme on est
pourquoi changer on va laisser les
choses comme elles sont
ça va se tasser c'est historiquement ce
qui arrive au québec année après année
après année moi je dis non
la responsabilité qu'on a comme
gouvernement s'est posé des gestes de
s'assurer qu'on a soit l'avenir sur des
bases solides notamment la partie de
solidarité de notre société à laquelle
je tiens elle n'est possible qu'avec des
finances publiques équilibrées et une
dette sous contrôle alors là dessus on
est très déterminé
on va avancer on va passer cet épisode
et on va avancer dans la prospérité
c'est ce que je souhaite maintenant mais
quand on vous dit peut-être que vous
manquez de sensibilité est ce que vous
l'entendez ce message là est ce que vous
sentez je l'entends mais c'est faux moi
je suis tout à fait conscient des
impacts possibles de ce qui est fait
méchamment conscient des impacts de ne
rien faire ne rien faire encore plus
d'impact pour les gens défavorisés les
personnes vulnérables je le répète un
discours de solidarité de compassion qui
ne s'appuient pas sur des moyens réels
c'est un discours d'illusions c'est du
vent moi je préfère montrer à la
population la réalité des choses à
corriger la situation et aller de
l'avant en maintenant le cap sur nos
principes de société auquel je tiens
également en campagne électorale vous
avez dit
lui parler de l'effet libéral sur
l'économie tardent à se faire sentir
comment elle va se faire donc la
création d'emplois la croissance parce
qu'on n'en parle pas beaucoup mais c'est
contrepoids de la rigueur budgétaire
je crois pas je crois pas que ce qu'on
fait actuellement nuit à la croissance
il ya très peu de preuves de sa au
contraire le bas sa croissance
le bas de la croissance dans le bourg
sens il arrive en 2013 alors qu'au
contraire on dépensait sans compter
et si la façon de faire croire que
l'économie s'était de dépenser 100
content de faire des difficiles
croyez-moi on s'en serait aperçu depuis
quelques années elle lui paraissait pas
preneur dans les entreprises prévues
introversion l'emploi elle vient par les
initiatives telles que le plan dans tron
va parler d'eux mais la stratégie
maritime les petites et moyennes
entreprises
l'hydroélectricité qu'on utilise pour
attirer les entreprises chez nous la
lutte aux changements climatiques qui
vont être un facteur de croissance
économique et non de décroissance il
numérique avec nos jeunes entrepreneurs
vous citer en premier le plan nord mais
le plan nord et du tributaire du prix
des métaux et on sait que les prix des
métaux sont en déprime totale en ce
moment donc est-ce que c'est pas risqué
pour l'arrivée ça va prendre des années
avant que c'est c'est un horizon qui
nous amène jusqu'à 2035 mais vous allez
voir demain qu'on va présenter les
travaux sur les infrastructures sur le
développement social des communautés
cela la protection des territoires
énormément d'occasions également de
développement là il n'y a pas que le
prix des métaux aidant les métaux il n'y
a pas que le faire et aussi des métaux
qui sont les minéraux qui sont très
attirants pour les investisseurs comme
les terreurs par exemple qui sont à
votre téléphone cellulaire ou d'un
moteur de 9 heures on a la chance au
québec d'avoir des gisements de grafite
aussi on a bien sûr le faire dont le
prix a baissé
un jour il veut remonter alors
profitons-en pour préparer ce grand
territoire que la nature et l'histoire
nous ont donné pour en faire une source
de prospérité mais également de
croissance sociale pour les communautés
moratti ait beaucoup à celle d'aller
voir demain on va parler autant de
questions économiques de développement
minier d'hydroélectricité que
développement des peuples autochtones et
développement de communautés humaines
non non vous aviez aussi promis un
projet de loi sur la neutralité
de l'état pourquoi ça tarde à venir
parce que je voulais le faire dans un
ensemble d'actions
d'ailleurs j'en ai parlé ce matin il y
aura des actions de sécurité
il faut le faire il ya des actions des
gîtes hâtives sur la radicalisation
menant à la violence dans le domaine de
notre juridiction qui le code civil il y
aura une politique d'immigration
d'intégration des immigrants et il y
avait la loi sur la neutralité de l'état
qui correspondrait l'opposition que vous
connaissez bien d'avant pendant et après
la campagne électorale tout ça va se
dérouler au cours des prochaines
semaines des prochains mois mais on va
le faire dans un ensemble cohérent où
les gens verront qu'une vision
d'ensemble de cette question qui est
essentiellement la question des
communautés de vie comment vivons-nous
ensemble avec la diversité il ya un
consensus au québec sur les
recommandations du rapport la commission
bouchard taylor sur le pour baliser un
peu la fonction publique
alors pas de signes religieux pour les
juges et les policiers les personnes en
contrôle
êtes vous d'accord avec ça j'en ai déjà
parlé - caen prenait n'existe pas je
vois pas pourquoi il faut faire une
solution on ne renvoie bien sûr nous on
a dit très clairement il ça va continuer
à être avec notre position on va jamais
accepter la discrimination n'en faut à
baser sur le port de signes religieux
jamais avec la seule exception du visage
caché qui d'après moi vos contre
beaucoup de choses auxquelles nous
croyons notamment de visibilité de la
femme son rôle et c'est ça pour la
réception et la prestation de services
publics ce soit dans nos orientations
mais d'empêcher une femme immigrante de
travailler ou un homme d'une autre
religion de travailler parce qu'il ou
elle porte un signe religieux qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire c'est pas
du tout compatible avec les valeurs
québécoises pour les gens qu'elle soit
sexuelle ici déjà d'accord les juges et
la magistrature c'est à eux de décider
en lui-même comme elle se gouverne et
pour les policiers montrez-moi encore
notamment un toit au québec vous ce
serait aller trop loin ça naturellement
oui parce qu'on n'a pas de cas concrets
skis ça prend pour les services
policiers
si un jour quelqu'un devait faire cette
demande ce sont des critères de décision
des critères d'analysé
il faut pas non plus dramatiser les
choses à outrance pu rester dans ce qui
est pratiqué réel ça fait un an que vous
avez été élu monsieur criard saleté
vous trouvez ça difficile
l'apprentissage du pouvoir pour ce
passionné et passionnant mais bien sûr
c'est un nouveau métier il faut en
prendre conscience faut voir les leviers
qu'on assume on a moins mais je suis
très content de l'équipe qui m'entoure
je suis très contente d'un capacité que
j'ai avec l'équipe te poser des gestes
qui vont améliorer la vie des gens et je
le redis avec beaucoup de certitudes et
de fermeté éclaircir l'horizon nos
finances publiques
avoir des politiques de croissance
économique et 300 emplois réduire la
fiscalité des gens qui est lourde au
québec
en définitive ça améliore la qualité de
vie des québécois et des québécoises
merci beaucoup mais ce qui s'est passé